madame monsieur bonsoir dans la crise
que traverse ce groupe eads noël
forgeard a donc décidé de s'expliquer se
défendant d'avoir eu la moindre
information des retards de production de
l'a380 au moment où il avait vendu ses
stock options en mars dernier le
coprésident du groupe européen et car
tout délit d'initié alors que certaines
critiques se font entendre sur les
règles de rémunération des grands
patrons vincent fourcade régis mettait
presque surpris de susciter un tel
intérêt
noël forgeard traverse pourtant une zone
de fortes turbulences
il est soupçonné d'avoir profité
d'informations privilégiées lui
permettant de vendre des actions à bon
prix
avant que les déboires d'airbus ne
devienne public aujourd'hui de noël
forgeard contre attaque et conteste le
délit d'initié qu'on lui reproche
oui les actionnaires ni les dirigeants
de eads n'était au courant c'est un
malheureux hasard vous pensez bien que
si j'avais eu la moindre information
privilégiée que je n'aurais pas vendu
ses actions
bon est-ce que je bénéficié
d'informations privilégiées
non mais atego rich man non mi mars
noël forgeard vent 162000 actions eads
et empoche une plus-value de plus de
deux millions et demi d'euros
puis le titre va commencer à baisser il
ya deux jours il s'écroule simple
coïncidence ou délit d'initié la mmf la
police de la bourse
même l'enquète noël forgeard at il vendu
ses actions en sachant qu airbus allait
mal à charge pour les enquêteurs d'en
apporter la preuve c'est tout boîte de
communication qui laisse une trace plus
ou moins écrite façon a rapporté une
preuve matérielle
ça peut aller du message électronique
jusqu'au fax aux rapports écrits
on courrier que peut accumuler une
direction générale l usine d'assemblage
du gros porteur les salariés semblent
avoir d'autres soucis en tête c'est
plutôt l'avenir d'airbus qui les
inquiète avant tout le problème c'est
qu'il ya 58 mille salariés airbus en
europe
c'est ça qui nous intéresse plus que de
savoir si monsieur forgeard à ses
enfants en réaliser des plus values ou
pas car en 2007 airbus ne pourra livrer
que neuf a380 au lieu de la vingtaine de
prévu et cela va coûter cher un demi
milliard d'euros de bénéfices en moins
pendant quatre ans